[Applaudissements]
on est alors moi j'ai été épaté par la
prouesse technique quand même qui
consiste à enregistrer pendant la pub le
petit morceau spectacle qui passe
pendant qu'ils allaient pub et après ils
reprennent un très très très léger
différé n'y a pas eu une merde technique
est formidable vraiment vous êtes
éclater toute la soirée isabella moi
j'ai adoré ça c'est que je t'aime attiba
je suis prêt oui mais moi j'ai mangé là
j'ai la preuve que vous êtes éclaté hier
en spectacle de gad elmaleh regardez
j'ai une photo de vous non
le baril
mais je suis en train de regarder mon
pour toi tu as ta place et tudor
isabelle isabelle si vous gardez pas
votre portable à isabelle arrêté je
serai taper la moto taxi pour aller
dormir sur place avant que j'habite à
plutôt juste à côté de boulogne un
passionné je regarde alors vas voir un
aussi le monde sait bien maintenant
vraiment ça nous amène hectares où
j'adore mais là si vous regardez votre
prix note fut ni la raison à les voir
rester au regard de sa mère
maintenant allez voir je pense ils
pensent qu'elles regardaient vraiment
important non je vais vous dire il y
avait les cerbères qui passait tout le
long et des quelqu'un levé son portable
disait portable voilà pour moi du coup
je me suis penché je vous dire la vérité
je sais mon attachée de presse qui m'a
envoyé la photo parce qu'elle est
également attaché président et sociale
et elle m'a dit vabre 7e fracasse on
attendait tous pour vous raconter tout
le spectacle
ouais ouais mais en tormo on entend des
trucs